(slow bright music)
- [Narrator] A century ago
100,000 tigers roamed the earth.
Today those numbers have declined
to just about 4,000.
But in the forest of Eastern Thailand,
conservationists have
found new signs of hope
for this iconic species.
This Great Big Story was made possible
by B. Grimm, empowering
the world compassionately.
(birds twittering)
Until recently it was believed
that the Eastern forests
of Thailand didn't have enough wild tigers
to maintain a breeding population.
But a group of conservationists led
by Panthera, the Thai
department of National parks
and the Freeland Foundation went out
into the jungle to find
out for themselves.
- We set up around 83 stations of cameras.
Each station has two cameras.
The general goal of setting
up the camera trap grid was
to estimate how many tigers are there.
What potential is there
for them to recover
in that area.
Camera trapping is always fun
'cause you have these cameras out for 45,
60 days in the field.
And they're out there
every day taking pictures,
so you bring them back and you've got
you know lots of people looking
at all the photos.
Clicking through what's next,
what's next, what's next.
And we discovered that we
have a breeding population
of tigers there.
This is kind of the first
evidence of breeding
for at least I think a decade.
It's a really amazing thing
to have been able to see
and to document.
Tigers are a symbol of a
healthy intact ecosystem.
To have tigers disappear from the wild,
especially when we have the means
to stop that from happening, would be
an absolute tragedy.
So although the survey
results are great news
we really do need to keep the pressure on.
I mean there's the threats
aren't necessarily abating
at those areas.
So the good work that's continuing
with patrolling on the ground,
law enforcement, working on trying
to give tigers a chance to breed
to have the area they need to persist
is really important.
(slow bright music)